and one of the things that i pointed out
earlier in my writing last year which
was so
it was so influential and a lot of my
articles went viral right away was that
race is not a barrier to my success like
i live such a privileged life stop
telling me that i
suffer from you know racial disadvantage
or that other people have white
privilege that's helping them get ahead
like i found that to be totally
counterproductive and pathological like
that whole narrative why why was it why
did you regard it that way
because i want to take ownership of my
own life and there is no supernatural
force of racism that's keeping me down
right like i can write essays and
publish my work in all these influential
places and i get to talk to you here
right now and i'm at a fairly young age
and i'm doing all these important things
race has impacted me yes but it's not a
systemic barrier it's not stopping me
from succeeding in life but that seems
to be the narrative perpetuated by so
many white people especially that there
is this
overarching force of of of racial
victimization that's at play and so i
stepped in yeah well i think part of
that too on the part of the of the white
people let's say
is that they get to have and this is
something that really bothers me about
the radical left um
you get your privilege and you get to be
more morally superior because you're
standing up for the victim so it's like
you get to be privileged and a victim at
the same time it's like hey pick one
okay
like maybe it's just too much to be
privileged and a victim at the same time
and that really um i've that i
it's it's not a
an effective psychological practice it's
terribly socially divisive and it's
unbelievably hypocritical
[Music]
hi everyone this is rav aurora
independent journalist based in
vancouver canada most frequently
contributing to the new york post and
the globe and mail
and i am most known for writing about
crime
policing racial identity politics and
vaccine mandates
the following wide-ranging conversation
with jordan peterson and i centers on
the absence or decline of spiritual
experience in western
secular culture we specifically talked
about how
ideological worship and political
activism often unknowingly replaces real
spiritual practices and contemplative
traditions
unbeknownst to me at the time of this
recording several months ago
this whole conversation
gradually inspired my new journalistic
adventures in psychedelics mystical
experience and new
interesting mental health treatments
over the past few months i've been
exploring the possibilities of human
consciousness and inner healing grounded
in science and reason
and my new sub stack newsletter titled
noble truths with rav aurora documents
my experiences with psilocybin mushrooms
mindfulness meditation
and talking to sam harris about learning
how to live in the present moment and
breaking down the mechanics of mental
suffering
and my new essay published today
february 10th
documents my incredibly profound and
transformational experience with mdma
therapy in which i journeyed into
the depths of my subconscious mind and
gleaned new insights and lessons to
apply to my daily life
and as i write in this essay on mdma
therapy this whole process mirrors the
hero's journey in which the hero has a
call to adventure
and then eventually
the hero a part of him or herself dies
and then a new transformed self emerges
as jordan peterson has talked about
before several times with respect to
psychedelics in particular
so this whole conversation
inspired my new work and inspired my new
newsletter on sub stack dedicated to
psychedelics and spiritual experience so
i hope you enjoy this conversation and i
hope it similarly sparks a call to
adventure for inner transformation in
your life
away we go nice to see you
yeah
yeah so you devote a whole chapter in
the book about abandoning ideology and
political dogmas
um
now you know we as humans were we're
primed for meta-narratives right like we
we have spiritual impulses that need to
be satisfied and so
one of the struggles right now is that
religion is on the decline and it has
been for a number of decades and you
refer to niche in the book about god
being dead and his observation about
the rise of totalitarian ideologies
coming with the decline in religion and
the various problems that come with that
and
right now particularly among young
people and older people as well
we're seeing
politics replace religion we're seeing
people
now
replace spiritual meta-narratives with
ideological meta-narratives so
so
how do we how do we figure that out how
do we perhaps we're seeing that you know
that's one hypothesis and that's one i
favor
i did see polling data at one point for
example from the gallup corporation
indicating that
lapsed catholics were something
some multiple of times more likely to be
separatists during the heyday of the
quebec separatist movement and
i lived in quebec during that period
some of that period and
it did appear to me that
nationalism
was functioning as a replacement for
for lapsed catholicism i mean quebec was
an intensely catholic country
until the 1950s late 1950s so in some
sense they underwent their
transformation to a secular society
somewhat later than most other european
nations let's say
and i thought that was reflected in the
tremendous attractiveness of nationalism
as a spiritual movement and
one of the things i learned from
studying the psychoanalysts both freud
and jung in particular was that
jung i suppose
had to do with
separating ultimate moral authority from
the figure of the father
so you might say that as you mature it's
useful to replace your
to realize that your particular father
your specific individual father isn't
omniscient omnipresent and omnipotent
he's another person and you have to
realize that to some degree to become a
mature adult
and so you don't want to confuse your
father with the ultimate moral authority
and in the same sense it's
psychologically dangerous to confuse
political
explanations and ideologies with
religious and spiritual ideologies and
and movements
you don't want the political to carry
the weight of the spiritual i don't
think i think it's dangerous i also
believe that ideologies
essentially function as crippled
religions
so they have the motive force of
religious belief and
and the attractiveness of religious
belief which i think is actually a
necessity for human beings because we're
religious by nature
but
they're
they don't have the
symbolic complexity
that a religion has
a well-established religion with its
mystical elements and its dogmatic
elements
so
now you say too that religious belief is
on the decline certainly organized
church attendance
in some countries is radically declining
christianity is growing at an
unbelievable rate in china
for example so it's not necessarily a
global phenomenon but
i'd and with regards to abandoning
ideology there's danger in confusing
your political beliefs and your
religious beliefs not noting that
there's a difference between them
they're one of the associated dangers
there i think in especially in
totalitarian utopian systems is the
proclivity to raise the leader whoever
that might be to the status of a demigod
that certainly happened in the soviet
union and in maoist china
maybe will happen again in in modern
china who knows as as
the chinese premier
centralizes his authority which he
appears to be doing
um you know you're supposed to render
unto caesar's that which is caesar and
render unto god that which is god that's
the
fundamental
ethos
that underlies the idea of separation of
church and state and i think it's a good
psychological truth as well
right so it's almost like
you can't replace
religion with politics like if you try
you'll only get let's say 60 of the way
there like you'll get the community
you'll get the group discussions you'll
get people who are like-minded who
want to
make change want to enact change but you
don't get that spiritual fulfillment at
all right you just get the community
part of it primarily right
well it doesn't seem to me to be the
right place to look for that spiritual
fulfillment yeah
i also think in the chapter from beyond
order so this is the book that we're
discussing beyond order um
there the the problem with ideologies as
far as i'm concerned is that they're
not
useful
as practical problem-solving guides most
of the problems that beset us are
very very complex and they need to be
decomposed in a sophisticated way into
their constituent elements
until they're differentiated enough so
that partial solutions for some of the
problem can arise as a consequence of
practical
endeavors
and that requires the willingness to do
that kind of detailed thinking
and it requires the development of
specialized expertise and
ideology can blind you to your own
stupidity and that's actually dangerous
um
so we could take the case of poverty for
example and
i think we could all agree that poverty
as such is undesirable
so that's the starting point and the
motivation then you might say well what
is poverty
and you could conclude that it's lack of
money and from that you could conclude
because there's an unequal distribution
of resources that if the rich would only
loosen their grip on
on wealth then there wouldn't be poverty
and then it's not much of a leap from
that to
the rich are by definition causing
poverty and morally culpable for it
and even though there is some truth to
that some of the time in some situations
that doesn't mean that it's always true
and it's the only reason all the time
and then there's an additional danger
which is that
you now have a solution and so you're
smart
you're not the problem so that you're
moral you have a convenient enemy so
your dark unexamined motives have a
valid target which you've already
defined as immoral and that means that
you're more likely to
give rain to violent impulses let's say
that you should otherwise keep in
control
and that's all very dangerous it's not
sophisticated it's emotionally and
motivationally dangerous it interferes
with proper problem solving it it
confuses you as to the limits of your
and and uh depth of your own knowledge
you end up thinking you actually
understand how the world works and you
don't understand it at all you don't
even understand the problems like think
about poverty
okay so what do you mean
by poverty
do you mean
alcoholism
drug abuse
mental illness physical illness
lack of education
lack of intelligence lack of
conscientiousness
uh anti-social behavior
relative poverty absolute poverty
do you mean uh
corrosive world view
do you mean lack of ability to plan for
the future
do you mean absolute privation of
material goods
that's all poverty and that's just the
beginning of a decomposition all of
those problems are markedly different
and it isn't obvious that there's one
solution that will address
it's not obvious at all in fact it seems
highly improbable that one solution is
going to address all of them
and then there's the complex problem
that
you have a theory that
identifies a problem and explains its
existence and offers a solution and so
now you're going to assume that if you
could only put that solution in place
that you would do that competently and
it would produce the result that's
intended
that's wrong
it's unlikely that you would do it
competently because it's very very
difficult to solve a problem and even if
you did it's also unlikely that your
intervention would produce
only the positive result that you intend
and nothing else
well that's that's a lot of problems
yeah right and then the ideology i
suppose it's the it's the enticement to
pride that ideology
also produces well now i have an
explanation for how the economic system
works uh no you don't
you don't know the first thing about it
you're like a monkey looking at a
military holocaust helicopter
right you don't have a clue and you
don't even know it
okay yeah so let me just uh
contextualize this uh topic here so
among
young people here in the west here in
canada certainly and in the united
states
members of gen z particularly
there's this growing
sort of uh political culture right now
where
young people are out protesting the
patriarchy protesting against white
supremacy and they've turned that into a
religion they've they're fighting
against this evil satanic force of sorts
which is white supremacy or it's you
know toxic masculinity or it's
transphobia islamophobia like these are
the things that they are fighting
against primarily opposed to fighting
sort of the the monster within so
there's kind of like an external locus
of control here right it's fighting
against the external opposed to the
internals well this is why and i outline
this to some degree in beyond order and
also in my first book maps of meaning
there are there are
the world is
characterized by ignorance and
malevolence and danger
always
always always it's an existential
truth
and then you might ask yourself well
if that's the case how might you best
conceptualize that
now
you can find malevolence and ignorance
at the level of the individual
and so we would say that's the
malevolence and ignorance that
characterizes
you
and other individuals and it's a it's a
viciously powerful and terrifying force
and then there's the malevolence and
ignorance that characterizes social
institutions
that's the great father that the that's
the negative aspect of the great father
in in my terminology and that's derived
to some degree from union theory
especially through a man named eric
neumann
who is a brilliant student of of
of jung
you're always a victim of the evil
tyrant
and the reason for that is that human
beings have a lengthy period of intense
socialization
and
that
fosters and develops your individuality
in some ways but crushes and maims and
distorts and destroys it in all sorts of
other ways
and so
it's a universal tendency to feel
oppressed by the evil tyrant
and it's so powerful symbolically it's
such a powerful symbolic tendency that
people don't even notice that it's a
symbolic tendency so i've been taken to
task for example for insisting that
we use
gendered metaphors to
portray the two
fundamental attributes of experienced
reality chaos and order
order
is patriarchal that's the symbol well
people accept that
at face value and don't even notice that
they're trapped in a symbolic world the
very feminists who will criticize me for
pointing out that femininity is
associated with chaos symbolically
except the idea that masculinity is the
proper representation for social order
without question and are irritated
beyond belief if you uh point out that
things are not so simple they're caught
in a myth a religious myth
and they don't even realize it and so if
you accept that the patriarchy is
masculine well then what's feminine
well the opposite of patriarchy and
order and that's
creative chaos and that's not my theory
that's the taoist theory of of being for
example it's the ancient greek chaos and
cosmos theory of being it's an un it's
it's the uh
ideational structure that underlies the
first chapters of genesis where
god makes order
out of a patriarchal god makes order out
of tohu vabohu which is the primordial
chaos
so
now
young people find themselves motivated
to stand up against the evil tyrant and
of course they should because it's at
that point when you're differentiating
yourself
that you want to take a look at the
group that you're going to pledge
allegiance to and note its
its its shortcomings
but
you don't want to be blind while doing
that and fail to notice that well
the social world is full of pathology
and danger malevolence and ignorance
let's say but the natural world which
you will automatically tend to
romanticize if you only believe the
patriarchy is evil the natural world is
doing everything it can
to kill you every second
and the only reason you're not dead
is because the evil tyrant has a
benevolent aspect that protects you in
ways that
are so deep and profound that you don't
begin to understand them
i mean you are shielded as am i by a
nuclear umbrella for example
none of which you have to attend to and
and then the other loss of course is
that
yes there's evil in the patriarchy
that's always how things are and
sometimes it's much worse than other
times
uh not right now by the way
uh not by historical standards but it
also blinds you to the fact that you're
culpable too
deeply you have
more ignorance and malevolence in your
soul than you'll ever get into on top of
in your entire life and that should be
part
that should the knowledge of that stops
you from being
carelessly judgmental carelessly
you should be judgmental
you have to differentiate and
discriminate between things
but
you shouldn't do it carelessly and you
certainly shouldn't assume that all the
fault lies outside which is the point
that you made and so ideology is
extremely dangerous if it
convinces young people that the moral
stance is that all malevolence and
ignorance lies outside of them
right yeah what do you think is
motivating this kind of hallucinatory
interpretation of our society being
uniquely
racist sexist homophobic like there's
this kind of self delusion going on here
where
well some of it's ignorance right and
and i mentioned this in one of my
colette essays about our our society
being one of the most free liberal
open-minded inclusive societies that has
ever existed right it is the most the
most for ethnic minorities sexual
minorities transgender folks all of that
but yet there's this narrative that
that you know me as a as a brown person
as an immigrant from india like somehow
i'm more of a victim than you are that i
live under this
on average
you might be somewhat
because it's probably harder to be a
minority in any culture than it is to be
the majority but
it isn't accounting for
it isn't the fundamental determinant of
the outcome of your life it's one
element and it's it's an important
element it's it's not good for anyone if
prejudice
doesn't allow us to use all available
human capital
right even from a purely selfish
perspective yeah it's foolish
so and why do we think that a lot of
it's ignorance you know people don't
know
for example that
the up until 1880 95 of the western
world live below today's un established
poverty line
we have no idea how
much dramatic improvement has been made
in the last 150 years and how absolutely
god-awful things were before that it's
and we don't know that because we've
never
been hungry for example not for one day
right okay so now that we've laid out
that yes we are living in the most free
open-minded inclusive societies on earth
then what's driving this this
well ignorance is part of it right we
just don't know and you look around and
you see well things could be better so
they're bad it's like true things could
be better and right that is bad well bad
compared to what well certainly bad
compared to a hypothetical ideal
but not bad compared to all extant
historical comparisons
so but you need but that requires
differentiated knowledge and once you
have the ideology you don't need the
differentiated knowledge because you
already have the explanation plus it's
convenient you don't have to look at
yourself and you have an enemy and
that's the part that scares me the most
you see i mean you don't have to look at
yourself yeah that's a bad but
now you have an enemy and that enemy is
the cause of everything you hate and now
you have all moral justification to go
after them to hurt them to stop them
because they're evil and to elevate
yourself morally as a consequence so you
have this unearned pathway to moral
superiority that's actually dependent on
your willingness to unfairly persecute
based on your ignorance
it's terrible and universities promote
this while you should be an activist
that's essentially what every 19 year
old is taught
it's like no you shouldn't be an
activist you should
you should get your own house in order
and then you should cautiously proceed
to more difficult things if you dare
right yeah and you can be an activist
when injustice happens which it does
just the problem that i'm finding right
now among young people is
the complete fabrication or at least and
a total exaggeration of injustice
happening like yes something bad happens
yes if there is an act of racism or
sexism let's fight it
but this whole idea of
our society being governed by
these uh these supernatural kind of
forces of white supremacy and patriarchy
it's it's almost like i'm listening to
these people i'm talking to young people
they are supernatural forces in some
sense yeah i mean symbolically speaking
yeah white supremacy is satanic
yeah and and the patriarchy is the evil
king and it's got a satanic element too
and that's the loc that's the
transcendental symbolic locale of
malevolence and evil and those things
are have to be contended with but you
have to do that in a sophisticated way
or it's better if you do it in a
sophisticated way you know there's
there's other technical issues at
you know here as well that we have to
attend to
um we're so connected
that any
instance of racial injustice is
immediately broadcast across our
experiential landscape and so if you ask
people the social psychologists have
established this if you ask individuals
how much
prejudice has interfered with their
movement forward
they generally claim that they they've
been relatively unscathed they've
emerged relatively unscathed but if you
ask them to what degree their group has
suffered or is still facing impediments
they rate the group
uh victimization as much higher than
their own personal victimization well
you hear about all the group
victimization plus now you add to that
the fact that we have
a bias towards negative information we
find it more
uh informative in some sense and that's
perhaps because we should be alert to
areas of danger
you don't see headlines of racial about
peaceful non-eventful racial harmony
which is what exists almost all the time
it's not news that you know i can walk
by you your skin is slightly differently
colored than mine and we can walk by
each other on the street without hacking
each other to death with machetes that's
not news thank god
but how do you make peaceful you know
infinite instances of peaceful
coexistence
newsworthy yeah you can't you can do it
with historical comparison yeah
so
so that's a big problem and some of this
is probably a positive feedback loop
gone astray
we paid more attention to issues of
racial prejudice and perhaps that was
good in many ways but because we're
doing that more attention is being paid
attention to it and it becomes more and
more salient and you can see that that
can ease especially given all the new
communication technologies and the rate
at which outrageous occurrences can be
distributed and our intense difficulty
at separating at establishing base rate
it's like well
who knows how many
racial
incidents of hate there are per day in a
given city is that going up or down well
we as individuals we don't know that the
historical answer is it's obviously
going down way down really fast sure
yeah and one indication in my view of
just how rare and marginalized uh racial
prejudice is right now is when
people are fabricating claims about
racial prejudice or exaggerating them
significantly so
uh there was a recent shooting in
atlanta
that happened which was horrible the
atlanta shooter he went to three
different massage parlors and he killed
a number of people and out of the eight
deceased victims six were asian women
and
and if you look at
all of the available evidence right now
and if you
uh
if you read what the actual shooter said
about his motivation he said that it was
due to his sexual addiction and he was
addicted he was addicted to pornography
and he also seemed to be kind of a
religious fundamentalist type of person
who who felt guilty and he felt
and he felt very ashamed about his his
sex addiction and he would go to these
massage parlors to get these other
illegal sexual uh services there and he
felt he felt bad about doing it every
time but he kept on doing it and so
there was this circular kind of battle
that he was facing and so then one day
he thought this temptation is bad i know
it's bad but i can't i can't stop myself
from doing it so why don't i go and just
physically
murder these people so that's a good
of demonization exactly what i was
talking about before it's like right his
problem was within there's a societal
element to that uh um
perhaps the the uh transformation of our
society so that pornography is so
rapidly accessible but we can leave that
aside for the time being
he had an internal moral struggle and
instead of dealing with that at the
individual level he demonized the handy
enemy those women who are tempting me in
this satanic manner um essentially right
opposed to my own uncontrolled sexual
impulses that i need to get in order
right yes right right precisely but so
the point that i wanted to make here was
about the media response okay so we just
discussed basically in a nutshell what
the current uh motivation seems to be
here
but the new york times usa today cnn the
guardian all these big outlets they all
jumped on racism in their headlines you
know a racist shooting uh america's
story of sexualized racism and so this
other no some of it's some of it's a
baseline problem right you said six out
of the eight were asian okay well six
out of eight of the normal population
the general population aren't asian and
so it looks like a preponderance of
asians but then you have to take the
local environment into account well most
of the sex workers in that area were
asian so then the question is well did
it deviate from baseline but that
requires sophisticated thinking to ask
that question and willingness to dig in
and the newspapers you know they're be
they're becoming uh in some sense
desperate yeah they're not doing well
they they don't have the resources they
once had and they're very likely to jump
on something salient and salacious and
and and then of course also
the most effectively salacious
uh article tends to rise to the top so
that's another feedback loop that we are
caught in and and don't know how to
regulate
right yeah and obviously you know six
out of eight victims being asian women
you know people make this mistake all
the time of confusing disparities with
discrimination just because well they
make that mistake because
sometimes disparities are a consequence
of discrimination right and sometimes
some well and and often enough so that
it's a reasonable hypothesis right
but
often i mean
look um
it's definitely the case that in the
united states in particular
native-born black americans are
underrepresented in positions of
authority power and economic dominance
right okay and so you might say well
that's a consequence of systemic racism
and there's no doubt an element of
systemic racism the question is how much
of the outcome is that accounting for
okay so and and you might say well we
could use that as the default hypothesis
given the history of slavery and it's
which which is
clearly
unacceptable in every possible way
morally although pretty much par for the
course for most human societies
throughout history right right and and
jim crow and other discriminators yes
policies afterwards right so you say
well systemic racism and fair enough
that's a reasonable hypothesis well
except that
there's a disproportionate number of
other minorities who are over
represented in in pinnacle positions and
in fact that's
that is happening compared to the
cocaine you know the native-born
caucasian
group
indian americans for example
their family income now is almost twice
that of the typical median caucasian
family twice and the top six or seven
are all southeast asian
so then you say well if it's systemic
racism
what about you know maybe you could
write off the indians and the muslims um
because they're more or less caucasian
and and i don't mean that positively or
negatively
but then the the the chinese the
japanese the koreans they're more
visually
different than caucasians but they're
doing just fine too
and and then if you assume systemic
racism it also blinds you to all sorts
of other factors as we already discussed
that might be contributing so i know for
example and i looked at into this 20
years ago that
it looks like it's the familial
structure an ethos of southeast asian
first generation immigrant families that
are producing over performance in their
children that disappears by the third
generation as assimilation completes
itself so
among southeast asians the emphasis on
conscientiousness essentially perhaps
with an additional um what would you
call it positive aspect of
higher
higher likelihood of intact family
two-parent family there's this emphasis
on conscientiousness and
conscientiousness is essentially hard
work southeast asian students that's
children of first-generation southeast
asian immigrants do homework spend many
more hours on homework
well conscientious driving actually does
predict success and the data that i
reviewed this was two decades ago
indicated that
the typical southeast asian child
gains uh competitive advantage from the
conditions of their upbringing that's
equivalent to 15 iq points yeah and
that's a huge difference it's the
difference between someone who's normal
and someone who's borderline uh impaired
mentally
handicapped
it's the difference between the typical
high school student and the typical
college student it's a walloping
difference well now if you if it's if
you're blinded by the fact of racism to
everything else because racism exists
then you're not going to be able to
decompose the problem and say well look
those south east asians they're
outperforming
southeast asians who are third
generation in the us also caucasians
why
well it looks like there's familial
structure issues and an emphasis on work
well you don't want to miss that man
it's actually important yeah and also
the attitudes on life like in my collat
essay the peculiar racist patriarchy um
i looked into different attitudes
towards life towards education and one
interesting finding that i came across
was that if you look at various polls
asians asian americans are most likely
to believe in the idea of self-made
success they're most likely to believe
that if you work hard you can you can
achieve what you want in your life
compared to right a white supremacist
racist trope that's now uh what what
would you understand
well it's it's a form of microaggression
that's that's frowned upon whose
utterance is frowned upon in many
universities formally you can't say that
that hard work puts you ahead
it's like it's a microaggression and you
can see why look here's the reason it's
like yeah well there are lots of people
who are poor
who are poor and dispossessed
despite the fact that they've worked
hard
right they're they're ill let's say or
they're they're impaired in their
intelligence or they haven't managed an
education or there's all sorts of
reasons that that hard work isn't going
to work but that doesn't even bad luck
even bad luck of course tragedies that
happen in your life yeah yeah you get
hit by a bus because you're standing in
the wrong place
that's why you need
enough sophistication to look at a
multifactorial
explanation
right and even you know you can control
for economic status and still find some
of these racial disparities so
low income asian americans
have higher upward mobility compared to
low-income black americans and white
americans and hispanic americans so and
it's probably native-born black
americans because nigerians seem to do
pretty well and yes generally speaking
black immigrants to the united states
outperform just as just as let's say
people from the indian subcontinent
outperform native-born caucasians in the
u.s the
immigrant black population outperforms
the native-born black population in the
u.s by a substantial margin yeah even if
you look in this in the same city so
thomas soul has done some great research
on this in
the city of boston you have the
native-born black americans and you have
the immigrant black american group and
the the immigrant black american group
their performance is much higher their
education rates their
high school completion their earnings
they're much higher but so in that same
city right whatever force of systemic
racism that exists it's constant right
because you can't distinguish between
somebody from nigeria versus somebody
who's black well you might think that
it's actually worse for the immigrants
because they have an accent and and you
know there are other
there are other features that mark them
out as strange different right they're
unacculturated to the various norms in
society lower rates of
english speaking proficiency all those
things matter but there seems to be this
kind of disinclination towards
behavioral explanations for success
there only seems to be sort of external
prejudice based explanation so
well part of part of it is that people
are loathed to blame the dispossessed
yeah and fair enough but but
fair enough it it's it's it's reasonable
to check yourself against doing that
because you can pass the homeless person
on the street and say if you weren't so
goddamn useless you'd get a job it's
like well you know um maybe
but
maybe not and there but for the grace of
god go i which is something always
useful to keep in mind but the problem
with
not assuming that individual
planning and diligent effort and moral
evaluation and ambition
matter is that you take away
the very tools
you deny the validity of the very tools
that could be most effectively used by
most individuals who are dispossessed
and that's a terrible thing to do i mean
the reason i emphasize individual
responsibility there's two reasons one
is
well you can start right now right where
you are no matter what you're doing so
you have that at hand
second
if you become more responsible
you probably won't hurt anyone by doing
it
right it removes the convenience of the
enemy and that's given how terrible it
is for us to
generate say class-based explanations of
enmity or racial-based explanations of
enmity that's something we really have
to step carefully around
i mean the worst crimes the human race
has ever committed have been generated
by class-based hypotheses of malevolence
class or or ethnicity-based hypotheses
of malevolence it's terrible
and and we need to avoid that and i
don't see that adopting more individual
responsibility even though it's not a
cure-all
it doesn't
that's one danger it doesn't pose in my
estimation
right yeah and just to go back for a
second to the the white supremacy
discussion and the different racial
groups
you know that whole narrative seems to
be on life support right now the idea of
white supremacy being the governing
force of western society whether it's
the us or canada so so one thing that i
mentioned in the colette essay the the
main
finding that i was exploring there was
the fact that last year for the first
time in history
uh asian women had higher earnings than
than white men did
for earnings in 2020 and this was
where where was that in the us in the us
and this was controlling for uh
full-time working asian women so that
was the
variable
full-time yeah but that's a staggering
finding and the difference was very it
was marginal but still for for you know
there are various gender differences at
play here but that finding is is
completely
uh it shatters the whole narrative of
race and gender for that matter and the
whole intersectional claim of race plus
gender
you know giving but certainly
complicates it very giving you various
disadvantages and so i looked into this
i said i you know i went on this
about two months i looked into the data
and i and i wanted to answer that
question of why
why are asian women making more than
white men what what are the
explanations and and
a few of the things that i found was
that
asian women are least likely to have
kids out of wedlock compared to women of
other racial groups
they have uh less kids on average
compared to other groups
um and they tend to have kids later
so the median age for having kids is
about five to ten years later compared
to
white women black women hispanic women
um and they tend to have
more family support in raising their
kids they tend to have more support from
their parents grandparents and helping
raise their kids another advantage to
intact family structure another
advantage now you know moral judgment is
irrelevant here right you know i'm not
saying that you know you should have
less kids or you should have more kids
but no but you connected a limited moral
judgment
you can say if you want to be hyper
competitive in the male dominated
capitalist environment here's the
sacrifices that are useful
right it's a bounded moral claim right
because you don't have to say well
that's how you should be who knows how
long you should put off having children
but if you want to compete economically
that might be a strategy that doesn't
mean it's in that doesn't mean it's an
advisable strategy no no and that's not
the only way to be happy in life too
right like if it's maybe not even the
most effective way sure yeah if a woman
doesn't want to work so many hours and
and have less kids and devote so much
time towards education career right
that's that's her choice right but
these explanations these factors that i
just laid out for you
this explains so more having more stable
families
more financial security and more time
devoted to pursuing a career these are
the results of having kids later having
less likely to have kids out of wedlock
right these are some of the consequences
of these decisions but
these behavioral explanations just seem
sort of taboo in a way because the
implication there would be that
if you make these decisions if you
if you take responsibility
you can actually achieve success it
doesn't matter if you're asian or if
you're a woman and of course there is
sexism of course there is anti-asian
bigotry which seems to be on the rise by
the way in canada and the us over the
past year since coven started right all
those things exist
but they're not a barrier to success
right they don't stop you from getting
ahead in life but the narrative seems to
be that it is which just seems totally
perverse and counterproductive to me
well it is it it it has perverse and
counterproductive effects there's no
doubt about that and those can get very
badly out of hand
um
any political movements that are
motivated by resentment any actions that
are motivated by resentment are
uh to be viewed with extreme skepticism
it's it's a very very very dangerous
state of mind resentment
right so yeah
now
going back to the earlier discussion we
were having here about spirituality and
young people
so observing that young people are
becoming sort of increasingly
politically active they're engaging in
this protest culture this fight against
these various forces that they've
identified and it's being incentivized
by the university by mainstream media by
hollywood celebrities you know people
posting about racism all the time and so
there's this exaggerated sense of this
problem existing
so all of that
being true
you know how do young people
get out of that position how do they
find and this is a question that i
really want to ask you here is how do
young people
find a value system to adhere to given
that religion is on the decline given
that
religion doesn't seem cool or
just for whatever reason it's not
resonating right ideologies resonating
not religion but how do we replace that
with something spiritual that fulfills
our
inner innate desires to strive for
you know god the infinite being the
divine whatever name you want to use for
that
well we could take that apart i mean
sure you might say well what might you
replace an ideology with and i would say
well
a differentiated
view of and strategy for life
and so when i work with my clients i
never start with high order problems to
begin with like how do i orient myself
spiritually so let's just leave that
aside for a second okay we'll return to
it
so
what do you need to get straight in your
life
well
you need a job
or a career career preferably perhaps
the advantage to a job is that you do it
for eight hours let's say and you're
done
right with a career
you're in it all the time now you'll
make more money you'll advance up the
economic hierarchy but
you're never done with work if you have
a career
and maybe that's what you want but in
any case you have to have a job or a
career why well you
you don't want to starve you want to
take care of yourself and the people
that are dependent on you they're
practical obvious practical reasons but
there are psychological reasons too
i mean
a job gives you something to do every
day just as your career does and it's it
also
um addresses the deep human need to be
of value and service to other people
and
so
that needs to be attended to so if
you're a young person it's like okay get
have a plan you need a job and a career
it would be good if it was something
that you could be competent at
so the smarter you are pure iq the more
complex job you can manage
and then if you add the development of
discipline to that
so that's the development of
conscientiousness that can further you
so you need conscientiousness and
intelligence to be competent and the
more hard-working you are and the more
intelligent the more complex the job you
can manage
so if you're of average intelligence
which you've probably figured out by the
time you're 18 or so
um it's going to be very very difficult
for you to be a high-end corporate
lawyer
unless you work insanely hard
so your better bet is to pick a
profession that isn't so cognitively
demanding that's still
useful and
trades are great as far as i'm concerned
there it's not like trades people aren't
skilled and it's not like intel it's not
like trades don't require intelligence i
am not saying that
but
um
it doesn't require as much abstraction
generally speaking like if you want to
be a lawyer you have to be hyper
literate
and like 90th percentile literate
fundamentally and you have to be able to
formulate verbal arguments or you're
going to get crushed by someone who can
do it okay so
job and career you need a plan
okay
education you should be as educated as
you are intelligent you should have a
plan for that yeah okay and it should
continue because things change quick and
you better keep up okay so you should
have a vision of that
um people don't seem to do well without
an intimate relationship
uh it'd be good if you could have a
family and bring peace to the family
that you have because family is
important uh extraordinarily important
those connections so intimate
relationship and family whether that's
your parents your siblings or the family
that you start you need a plan for that
a vision of that
um you have to take care of your
physical and mental health you have to
regulate your drug and alcohol intake
you have to figure out how to make
productive and meaningful use of the
time that's allotted to you outside of
your obligations
that's extraordinarily useful and
you have to address your philosophical
or spiritual
slash aesthetic yearnings such as they
might be
well so that's better than an ideology
a plan
sure
right now you know and as you climb up
your career as you expand your
competence and power well then you can
get involved in
larger scale transformations if that's
where your interest takes you
and so with job and career you should be
competent and interested in it that's a
good
pathway to success
all right so
so
that's the right place to focus as far
as i'm concerned if you're a young
person it's like well have a plan have a
plan
right make a plan and and then educate
yourself
because you're much more powerful and
competent if you're educated
right so so why not do it yeah but the
thing is if you have a plan that's great
and young people should have a plan and
they should stick to it and they should
they should have a vision for themselves
of what they want to do and they should
persevere towards that vision but the
problem is finding
meaning is like
what oh look we worry about that
afterwards look we outline domains of
meaning
look
family is meaningful right career is
meaningful you can mentor people helping
other people develop that's extremely
meaningful
a lot of the high-end people that i've
seen who are extraordinarily successful
in the socio-economic domain derive a
tremendous amount of their meaning from
fostering that development among young
people
and so so there's micro meanings to be
found in all of those domains now you
still might be searching for something
transcendent
right whether you know it or not even
like well something something you think
is some kind of something you need as
like the analogy would be like a crush
right when you're striving towards your
vision and things don't go your way
tragedy happens malevolence happens as
you say
um and you're suffering in your life you
need some kind of base meta-narrative
something you know whether it's prayer
or meditation
or you're reading various types of
scriptures something to give you meaning
to give you
hope
faith and trust in something else and
just let you know that that you're not
in this alone that you can get to where
you want you need that kind of emotional
spiritual crutch in your life and this
is what i wanted to ask you about is
that young people
they seem to have that less and less so
how do we find that spiritual crush is
the question well i wouldn't say it's a
crutch i don't i don't think that's
that's reasonable because any genuine
spiritual practice uh places a
tremendous moral burden on its
practitioner so let's say foundation a
spiritual foundation
well and some people need that more than
others like if you're the sort of person
who and i would say that that's likely
associated with high trait openness
that's the creativity dimension and so
if you find yourself yearning well
how do you address that
literature
art
that's the domain and and then in that
domain there's the mystical religious
domain and the philosophical domain well
reading is your best way into that and
you also describe the ritual practices
and they can be very useful to people i
mean my wife found repetitive prayer of
aid when she was undergoing interminable
repeated scans for the presence of
cancer it's like well what do you do in
a situation like that well one thing you
can do is turn to a ritual and you might
say well that's a crutch it's like well
no it's a practice it's a meditative
practice that helps regulate your
physiological reactions under extreme
duress people who think that religious
belief is a crutch
first of all they're they're they're
guilty of something i think is an
unbelievable impediment to reasonable
progress which is
casual contempt like are you sure you
know enough about that to be
contemptuous of it
religious belief has a history that's
tens of thousands of years old
the capacity for religious experience
and perhaps even the need for it is
coded in us biologically
it's it's right unbelievably complicated
problem and solution you don't want to
casually dismiss it
there's you can read philosophers and
great great uh great writers and great
religious thinkers and great
psychoanalysts carl joseph campbell for
example is a great entry place for
anyone who wants to
take religious thinking seriously right
and so this is where i'm getting at here
is so you're saying spiritual experience
is encoded in our genes and i agree with
that whether you know even people who
say they're atheists or they don't
believe you know i think this is
universal for for everyone but for
people who don't have religion who just
have ideology well the atheists when you
watch star wars
right yeah you know the atheist
materialist types the engineers
skeptical and unlikely to personalize
the world they get their mythology
through science fiction and they don't
even notice it but people who don't have
that spiritual practice don't have that
religion who are watching star wars
participating in protests against white
supremacy how do they
how do they find that spiritual
experience how do they achieve that
state that's kind of the fundamental
thing that i'm wrestling with as our
society becomes more and more secular
and saturated with technology and
and political polarization all these
other forces that seem to be distracting
us from our inner
private need for for spiritual
experience i would say to some degree
that's the fundamental unanswered
question of our age
you know i'm reading this book right now
uh
is it the religion with no name
it's about the illusionian mysteries i
should get that right
the immortality key the secret history
of the religion with no name
so the
greeks greek society was grounded in
a spiritual experience and practice that
centered on ellucis i hope i have that
pronounced properly
the initiates were inducted into the
alessinian
mysteries
and this book
is one of a long line of books a
relatively long line of books really
started in the 1960s suggesting that
shamanic experiences which are tens of
thousands of years old perhaps older and
religious
practices in more sophisticated
societies that
were
profoundly influenced and affected by
hallucinogenic substances
it seems highly probable to me in fact i
think the evidence is incontrovertible
we have no idea what to do with that
fact now
the
hallucinogens the psychedelic experience
adds an experiential element to
religious belief religious thinking
um
but we don't know what we don't know
what to make of that we don't know what
to make of the fact that
apollonian greece this
shining beacon of rationality was
embedded inside a mystical psychedelic
experience
right right well and so our modern
religions
they're they're experientially dead in
in a very
unfortunate way and i mean that really
mean that it's unfortunate but even the
materialism is it suffers from the same
problem so so what do you what do you
mean by that that they're
they're dead what do you mean exactly
well if you go to a rave
even if you don't take any
substances
the music and the dance can produce an
experience that lifts you outside of
yourself
yeah an intense aesthetic experience can
do that
and
we have a
our religious structures in the west are
divorced from that to
to a degree that i think is is is
untenable over the long term
and
we insist upon faith
we insist upon a faith that the rational
atheist types find contemptible and have
very powerful arguments at their
fingertips to to drive home
dawkins and and sam harrison and and
hitchens those people are formidable
intellectually and and
they they take apart
at least from their perspective these
preposterous supernatural claims and and
leave everything in ashes on the ground
um
what to do about that i don't know i
mean i would say that's
something i think about all the time i i
mean i've been talking as well to people
like
bjorn lomberg and matt ridley
who are
these rational optimists who
note that
human material progress is progressing
michael shermer would be in that camp as
well
um human material well-being is
progressing at a staggering rate and
we're going to solve a lot of the
problems of absolute material
deprivation in the next 30 years and
that data is there and it's available
but it has almost no
compelling nature it's the same problem
we discussed earlier that yeah there's
not a story there like
when you take your ideal ideologue your
18 year old highly committed idiolog out
of the crowd and you say look
we're going to incrementally improve our
way out of absolute privation over the
next 15 years so just calm down
do something productive and wait
and they say to hell with you what i'm
doing is way more exciting which is true
and so
we we have a real problem we we don't
know how to marry
either
re formalized religious belief let's say
or even
utopian materialism in the enlightenment
manner we don't know how to marry that
to the dionysian
and that's a big now the thing about an
ideology is that that gives you the
dionysian man you can go you know so
you're part of black lives matter you're
part of anti-fun so what do you do
instead of being like 7-eleven clerk
and relatively unattractive romantically
by the way because of that particularly
if you're male you put on a mask and you
take your club and you go out to fight
evil and you know there's fire and
there's noise and there's the terrible
tyrannical police and like you get to be
a hero and that's real
now you can say well that heroism is
misguided and i would say it is
ultimately considered but it's not
obvious to me that the desire for
adventure that possesses the 7-eleven
clerk who's dissatisfied with his you
know
comfortable
satiety
the call to adventure is real
well it's it's it's incumbent upon the
culture to satisfy the call to adventure
right well we don't know how to do that
we don't know how to do that and so the
whole black lives matter thing or
fighting against uh even you know
climate change uh white supremacy the
patriarchy that then becomes the
spiritual mission then that becomes the
goal that becomes the vision opposed to
something truly spiritual and religious
right but so so one thing that i wanted
to
to question
one thing i wanted to pose to you here
was so so you're saying that in western
religious traditions
so you're saying that they are divorced
from spiritual experience is that what
you're saying
yeah they're divorced from practical
mysticism
you know you you can that's more
that's more of an eastern type of thing
right so like meditation contemplative
practice that's something that well
there are contemplative practices in the
west but very few people
very few people they're certainly not
popular like yoga
and there is mystical tradition in the
west and but
um
there's the
in in the mass celebration for example
which is eating the flesh of god
essentially a very very very very old
idea incredibly powerful idea
to incorporate the divine
there's a spiritual transformation
that's attendant upon that but it's it's
it isn't delivering what it promises
not
and not in any
self-evident manner and i think that's
probably because
we've lost the technology
that's my guess
strange as that is
you know
eliad who's a great historian of
religion wrote about shamanism and
and the typical shamanic experience
which by the way is replicated
experientially all over the world from
the the deepest reaches of northern asia
into the amazonian jungles the
experience is very similar that the
shaman report
um remarkably similar but we have the
same biology and
eliader believed that
those the shamanic practitioners who
relied on hallucinogens were practicing
a debased form of the of the religious
practice i think i i have great respect
for eliada i learned a lot that's
another person people can read as merce
eliade if you're interested in
spirituality he's an absolute genius
right um but i think he was wrong i
think the shamanic tradition was clearly
embedded in tens of thousands of years
of powerful psychedelic use i think the
data on that are pretty pretty much
clear
right yeah and you know
i've been to church many times before
and i've been to temples
and and so you know i come from an
indian background and my parents were
raised
with hindu and sikh religion in india
and so i was raised with sikhism
hinduism
i never really resonated with it and i
always sort of rebelled against
organized religion
and then
then came high school and
sort of i was i was
developing my identity and i had these
larger questions about existence and
about the world
and to some extent religion did help
with that and
and i did go to church for this short
period of time and that was very
interesting and i learned a lot of
things even if i didn't
you know let's say commit to being a
christian it was still learning the
lessons about about forgiveness about
mercy about
uh right right right well some spiritual
practice might be better than none sure
but but still but still going to church
and
and and i guess you know i don't want to
sound like i was fully immersed in that
environment because i i certainly wasn't
i wasn't practicing as a christian and
and obviously people who are practicing
christians they get something that i've
never experienced right so i can't speak
to that but for my limited time going to
church and also going to various uh sikh
and hindu temples as well
uh primarily sikh temples which are all
over canada
um
going there i just i still didn't feel
like i was having that spiritual
experience that i wanted to have i still
felt like there was something lacking
and so i was very confused for a long
period of time
i talked to bishop baron about that sort
of thing recently i'm going to release
that podcast relatively soon you know i
think one of the problems that the
modern christian church has
and i'm speaking broadly and out of my
place here to some degree is that
part of the reason that young people
aren't adhering to the religion is
actually because it demands too little
you know if you present and i've seen
this with my own undergraduates the ones
that i've taught because my course
especially maps of meaning which was a
primary course i taught for decades
had a very large impact on the people
that i was teaching and um and it it's
full of i religious ideas it's
psychology of religion course
essentially and
it
it was
i mean what i what i
strove to
transmit to my students was
a religious idea which is look
you're way more than you think
for good and for evil and actually the
easiest way to discover that is to take
a look at the evil
you can become convinced of your own
evil and terrified of that in a way
that's easier than to become convinced
of your own good in any case there's
more to you than meets the eye a lot
more and you're much more dangerous and
promising than you think
and what that means is that you have an
ethical requirement
to
discipline yourself and turn yourself
into something
because the world depends on it
and
the churches
they don't
say that
and that's what you have to say to young
people
it's like get yourself together
everything depends on you
your decisions are important and you ask
why people turn to ideology or maybe
even to atheism or nihilism it's like
it's no trivial matter to take yourself
seriously
yeah especially when you start to
you know i tried to learn the lesson of
the holocaust which is what
yeah everyone who
attempts to derive moral lessons from
the holocaust insists is the right
response what's the moral lesson
you're a nazi
you better get control of yourself
right you could delight in the torture
of other people
it's very frightening to realize that
yeah yeah you know when the church of
course the christian church
has a very well developed model of evil
it's very sophisticated christianity is
very sophisticated it's in its
representation of evil unbelievably
sophisticated
and that's
extraordinarily useful and necessary and
i think the church i don't think the
church demands enough of its young
practitioners it doesn't offer them
enough and it doesn't scare them enough
right so so i wanted to finish my
thought from earlier so what i was
saying was that participating in
organized religion sort of
ironically didn't seem enough to fulfill
my spiritual impulses and i could be
speaking
you know maybe not sort of in a
representative way maybe if i did fully
immerse in the religious lifestyle maybe
i could have achieved that state but for
me it just seems sort of
i don't want to use superficial i don't
want to use pejorative terms here but
but there was something more that i
needed and
and so then i sort of veered down this
path of mindfulness meditation and
contemplative practice
which did then
start to fulfill my spiritual impulses
you know meditating 10 to 20 minutes a
day
focusing on
all the
the
flurry of thoughts that are appearing in
consciousness and how
we seem to identify with these thoughts
and they completely needed to practice
yeah you know and that is something else
that yes the church the christian church
could offer to young people it's like
okay you want to be a christian okay
what do you do sure
you know maybe you volunteer at a
hospital
right so you need practice it's not just
religious belief religious
life isn't just belief right it's not
it's not a set of
philosophical propositions
it's also a practice and you found some
solace and some utility and a spiritual
discipline and so do many people you
many people study yoga and
so what's the christian equivalent of
that well well is there nothing is there
a christian
yeah well no there isn't one that's
popularized and and detailed and
available to people to practice there
are
mystical prayer traditions
yeah the rosary and the catholic rosary
is a form of meditative practice
right right yeah so okay so we we've
established that western traditions
western religious traditions are
divorced from spiritual experience right
we agree on that well they're divorced
enough so that they don't seem to be
they're not they're not motivating in
the same way for see you you oh you said
it yourself where we talked about this
well let's say you're an ideologue and
you've decided that the patriarchy needs
to be smashed well what do you do well
you go to protests
well that that's that's that's
smoke and fire you know it's dramatic
well if you're a christian a young
christian
yeah well what should you do
well
be good
well it's a little vague
sure yeah
yeah and
reaching those high states those
different states of consciousness where
you're aware
of your inner
primal impulses and how they can lead
you astray that seems to be something
that i'm finding
in
eastern spirituality in meditation being
aware of my own flaws and how
i sort of dupe myself with with all this
negative thinking and
identification with thought and you know
becoming practically a slave to whatever
internally or externally that i'm
experiencing whether it's an impulse to
do something or it's
you know somebody says something bad or
i don't get the job i want and that just
completely becomes my reality but and i
don't recognize that that is separate
from my own consciousness that i can
take a step back
and
not let it define my experience right
that is something profound that i'm
finding within mindfulness meditation
and so i think you can do that with
prayer and i think that's what the
purpose of prayer is that right well
imagine that you want to engage in a
practice that would orient you away from
evil and towards the good so that's your
goal
okay so you can ask yourself and this is
i would say this is a form of communion
with your hypothetical higher self and
perhaps it's through that that you
find your relationship with god
something like that speaking
psychologically you ask yourself well
what i'm what am i doing that's corrupt
and stupid
that's a prayer it's not oh i wish i
could find my wallet
you know when you lose it
you don't pray to god to help you find
your wallet yeah i mean i'm making fun
of it but yeah but you have to ask the
right question well what's the right
question how am i stupid and weak in a
way that i could change
and then maybe you ask well if i don't
want to change
but no i should well then you ask
yourself well
how is it that i could
take a step forward to wanting to change
and and so you can see even if you only
speak psychologically you posit an ideal
within yourself that you can commune
with
and then you ask that ideal
to guide you
well that will work that'll work
yeah now it may not be unerring or
infallible but you get better at it
across time what that might mean is that
god speaks more clearly to you across
time
right but again the the absence of
spiritual experience within within
christianity and other western
traditions
that seems to be an interesting place
where we're at right now so we've
established that so so are you saying
that
in some ways christianity and other
western traditions
aren't fulfilling our fundamental innate
spiritual impulses is that what you're
saying because you seem to be you know
throughout why would people be leaving
the church like we see these
unbelievably impressive magnificent
cathedrals emptying
well with some there's something wrong
we're doing something wrong like well
something wrong something something
wrong within the church or something
wrong within society right the other
increased political polarization the
rise of technology
secular ideas yeah both right well the
church is us
after all
you know
these medieval people
spent
vast fortunes and unbelievable effort
making these incredible places of
worship they're so beautiful that it's
right beyond
comprehension and
what's happening inside them is so
insipid
that no one will attend
well that's wrong look i learned
something when i was a clinical
psychologist about talking to my clients
if it was boring
it's the same with podcasts
if it's boring you're doing it wrong
there's a lie in it somewhere there's
so you know we're having a reasonably
intense conversation this is going well
we're both engaged we're doing it right
now maybe we're not doing it as well as
it could be done but here we are and
we're in it yeah
well if if that experience isn't being
offered by the church
yeah then the church is doing it wrong
well what's right well
i don't know well maybe i know a bit i
did a lot of lectures on the bible yeah
public lectures and they've been popular
can i put my finger on why
not easily
i took them seriously i took them
seriously i suppose now is that to say
the church doesn't yeah
it is to say that that
yeah the seriousness actually matters
like i took the story of cain and abel
seriously
i studied it for years trying to figure
out what the hell it meant
the story of adam and eve the story of
abraham
and those things have to be made alive
if you don't make them alive then you're
doing it wrong and as soon as they come
alive then they attract people
right and so it seems like we're
touching on this disconnect this
difference between religion and
spirituality they're not the same they
can be the same but here we're saying
they're not the same well they need to
be melded that's the dionysian and
napoleonian marriage that nietzsche
spoke of but it's also that it's the
place where dogma and spirit look
spiritual experience without structure
can make you insane
it's very very dangerous
but dogmatic structure bereft of
the mysticism and spiritual is dead it's
a corpse and and the proper balance is
somewhere in the middle and we've known
that as a species forever i mean the
egyptians regarded the highest god and
so he was the he was the
the embodiment of the principle of
sovereignty itself he was horus who was
the eye the capacity to pay attention
allied with osiris who was the patriarch
so it was this living
dynamism between
lived experience dionysian experience
even
and you know intense emotional highly
motivated and structure
well
that's where that's where valuable
religious experience the most valuable
religious experience occurs
right it doesn't tear you into bits
you know right which is the problem with
unbridled mysticism you say and the
problem with psychedelics
i mean when psychedelics were
reintroduced to our society it caused a
tornado a hurricane we had no idea what
to do with them
and so we made them illegal immediately
it's like wow we don't know what to do
with these things
you know and they've been reintroduced
into our culture after an absence of
several thousand years we have no idea
how to deal with whatever they are and
and we have no idea what they are sure
no idea and yeah and i would argue just
as a side note that the closest thing to
psychedelic experience is in meditative
practice primarily mindfulness
meditation you know people have talked
about this uh
ancient yogis and sam harris talks about
this as well about reaching states of
consciousness in consistent discipline
practice of meditation that is akin or
almost identical to
psychedelic experience which is very
powerful and and that's a different
whole conversation but so so you're
saying the the spiritual absence within
christianity
that's a problem that you're identifying
and that's a big problem you're saying
right it's a catastrophe
it's like it's a catastrophe nature knew
this lie 150 years ago right you know he
said god is dead and we have killed him
and we'll never find enough water to
wash away all the blood
so so modern christianity you're saying
is not centered on spirituality and
that's a problem just to be clear i'm
not saying it's not centered on it
exactly i'm and i'm not
i'm not criticizing it as if i'm the man
with the answers or as an outsider it's
our problem as westerners let's say
that our central religious core is has
been hollowed out
and
it's it's the fault of
everyone
that the church practitioners the
religious authorities it's their fault
but it's also the fault of
those of us who are let's say alienated
from the church
we we can't we we we haven't managed to
the proper spiritual relationship with
existence we haven't managed that we and
and that's a terrible catastrophe
interesting right it's and you know and
it's it's vitally important it's vital
it's it's more
important than anything else it's it's
the most important thing
right yeah it's just interesting to see
you make this observation which i
completely agree with but you always
seem to be a proponent of religion
speaking good about religion doing
lectures and debating sam harris about
these things while he is identifying
problems within religion yet you now
well the problem with the materialist
atheists is they don't leave people with
anything
you know dawkins for example who i
respect especially i just respect his
intellect in his his verbal capacity but
his conclusion is essentially well
it's a clockwork universe that's
meaningless right well you know people
take that sort of thing seriously
and it isn't obvious what you do when
you're a serious nihilist
and but it looks to me that if you're a
serious nihilist what you do is not good
it's not good to yourself
but it's also not that good to other
people
and so
it's and to think of all we've left
behind the whole shamanic tradition and
it's right ancient
ancient ancient roots
and
the greek mysteries and christianity to
leave that all behind and say well that
was nothing but primitive superstition
it's that's that casual contempt that i
was talking about it's like those people
weren't stupid and what you don't know
about religious experience would fill
many many many books
right right so don't just casually
dismiss it and perhaps that's that
spiritual experience is
is preserved within various eastern
traditions like buddhism and hinduism
again with the whole meditation well
pieces of it are certainly and and right
i mean there's no shortage of westerners
going to the amazonian jungle to
reacquaint themselves with shamanic
shamanic traditions and that's actually
how psychedelics were reintroduced into
western culture it was gordon wasson and
his crew who found magic mushrooms in
mexico and that launched the entire
psychedelic revolution we re-establish
contact with our lost shamanic past
we have no idea what the consequences of
that will be
and and no way of formulating it
intellectually in a manner that's
comprehensible or
or
we we don't know what to do with it
right so you so you're always a
proponent of judeo-christian values in
our society of some kind of religious
structure that we have right you're
always a proponent of that but right now
you're also identifying this fundamental
disconnect this kind of pathology almost
within
we're talking about christianity
specifically is that fair to say
yes
okay yeah do you see that as a
disconnect that you're always sort of
arguing in favor of religion when you're
debating sam harris but you still
no identify this pathology that exists
the father
the the the father is always
dying or dead and it's always your job
to revitalize them always you can't
leave the past behind
we are the past
you're old
us human beings
we've been around a long time
we can't just leave the past behind
right so you go back and with some
humility yeah and you think well we'll
sift among the ashes and if we can find
some
treasure
thank god we need it
and i said look look i i'm watching
people like lomborg and matt ridley and
and uh i just spoke with uh marion
toopey who runs humanprogress.org
he's another incremental
materialist optimist i say this with all
respect i'm i'm thrilled as everyone
should be that 200 000 people are being
lifted out of abject poverty every day
but we see that happening at the same
time we see this spiritual malaise grip
the west
to such a degree that we're undermining
our own
presuppositions
right
and we seem actively involved in this
process of destruction and i would say
well that's perhaps that's partly
because
these axioms are being challenged by
people who are angry for
for valid and invalid reasons and we
cannot mount a counter defense we're too
weak to defend ourselves well that's not
good
especially
because i do believe that
the west
got many many things right
yeah yeah and i think the evidence for
that is clear individual autonomy even
the protesters when they go out and
protest are acting out the proposition
that the west got things right because
they wouldn't regard themselves as
autonomous individual agents who have a
political responsibility if they weren't
saturated in western thinking
right yeah that is the great irony there
um and by the way have you ever tried
mindfulness meditation have you gone
down that eastern consciousness kind of
road have you been there or have you not
explored that in depth
i would say yes and no i mean as a
clinical practitioner
i did mindfulness meditation all the
time and i do that during podcasts and
interviews
you do it during interviews okay yes
because i watch
right i watch
and all i'm trying to do is watch
and say what i think
that's it i don't have a
ulterior motive in mind except to pay as
much attention as i possibly can to
what's happening
and to respond in his
untrammeled a manner as i can possibly
manage
right okay so you've thoroughly engaged
with mindfulness meditation well i don't
sit by myself and in contemplation i do
it in the way that i just described and
and try to fall into the
conversation
and that was very useful to me as a
clinical practitioner and it's been
extremely useful i would say as a
speaker and also as you know i'm doing
all these podcast interviews and that
sort of thing and when they go well
they're sure they're
they're they go well and and that's why
it's a tension i think i learned from my
studies of egypt of ancient egypt
that the eye is
sacred to pay attention
not to think it's different it's a
different thing right yeah and
ultimately the the barrier between
meditating sitting down and focusing on
your thoughts versus living your life
that barrier is artificial right the
idea well the goal is the goal is to be
mindful in your day-to-day exactly yeah
yeah the barriers artificial between
sitting down and practicing versus
living your life like you see people who
meditate so much you know consistently
yet if something irritates them they're
yelling right away and they're
screaming on the top of their lungs and
they're
right well people ask me sometimes how i
can maintain control of myself in
provocative interviews for example where
there's lots at stake and the answer to
that is what i just said is that i'm
paying attention
and i'm doing my best to say
whatever is appropriate to that
particular situation
right yeah i i can do that better
sometimes you know i get pvish and
irritable and
and when i'm off my feed let's say yeah
but when it works it really works
right yeah i guess the thing that i was
curious about here and maybe this is
unanswerable to some extent but i was
wondering if you've ever derived any
spiritual experience from
mindfulness meditation but maybe that's
something that uh in the future you
might well i've had powerful religious
experiences i would say as a consequence
of of of
attentional focus that's like that i
made this piece of art
called the meaning of music which is my
logo essentially and um
it took me four months to make it i
carved it out of foam core it's about
eight inches thick about 20 layers thick
and it's about six by six and i was
trying to understand
the meaning of music it was an
exploration and i had an intense
religious experience
well looking at it and what and
listening to mozart's 41st symphony at
the same time like i was completely
transported it was it was it was uh it
was
my pupils dilated completely
right yeah right it was an overwhelming
experience i mean that's half that
particular experience happened to me
three times in my life
wow okay and that was the consequence
you're saying of the mindfulness
practice well i kind of opened my mind i
thought i was looking at this thing that
i had produced which was also a mandela
it's a three-dimensional mandela and
some people who've studied jung will
know something about what that means
mandela is a symbol of potential it's a
symbol of the higher self it's a symbol
of possibility it's a symbol of
structure
i was
meditating on this mandela which moved
because that's how i designed it it
moves visually like music does and
listening intently to music music is
intrinsically meaningful
and what happened was that that sense of
intrinsic meaning magnified itself
intensely and that was the basis of the
experience right and it just it just
knocked me over and it was a complete
transformation of consciousness and i
thought i was in a different state of
mind i thought well i could be like this
all the time
and then i thought well i wouldn't know
how to conduct myself if that was the
case and then it
dissipated and
but it gave me a glimpse of it gave me a
glimpse of
of of
something i certainly don't understand
but certainly see
yeah maybe something into a psychedelic
experience yeah that's what i was going
to say and i do want to dig deeper into
this intersection of spirituality
religion meditation art this kind of
thing but i do want to move on to the
more important stuff here um so let's
talk about good luck
let's talk about uh victimhood here
victim culture
so so why do you think victimhood is so
attractive right now in our culture why
are so many young people and also older
people well there's two identifying as
victims along
along gender lines racial lines or just
just in general too there seems to be
this push against personal
responsibility and there's all these
psychological and sociological factors
at play here that are incentivized
within the culture within the media
within
within uh hollywood and all these things
so so that's kind of this cultural
pathology that i've identified here and
i want to hear your thoughts on that
well you know we you should always start
by giving the devil his due
right okay okay so um
one source of moral action is empathy
clearly and we admire
and even hold sacred
the empathic capacities of a mother
caring for an infant right it's a
primary religious symbol in many
cultures
certainly you see it in christianity
with mary and and christ but
it's not unique to christianity
and any society that doesn't hold the
mother and infant as a sacred image is
doomed
obviously
right because that means you don't like
mothers and children and so that is doom
literally
so okay so
so we can say well practice empathy
and you can see that that's
as if
insofar as morality can be encapsulated
in one statement that's not bad but it
can't be encapsulated in one statement
it's too complicated we're more there
isn't only one dimension of morality but
that is an important one and so well you
can't be too empathetic
yeah well yeah yes you can degenerate
into sentimentality and you can do too
much for people and you can over mother
them and so so it has its boundaries but
they're very difficult to
identify right opposite empathy looks
like predation
right yeah so somebody who's in a car
accident who's going through a difficult
time yes you want to care for them be
empathetic but at a certain point they
need that force of self-determination to
take action and get better themselves
from their business well that's the
tension isn't it and it's the
temperature yeah
it's the tension that every parent faces
it's like well you have to take care of
your infant but as the infant matures
you retract the care
yeah and let them because then and if
you don't the empathy
the reflex of empathy that you would
show towards an infant is is downright
pathological if you're dealing with a
three-year-old and absolutely
counterproductive if you're dealing with
a competent adult let's say yeah
somebody who's rehabilitating from an
injury or drug addiction right empathy
is not limitless right there are
constraints at play here and there is
some virtue in personal responsibility
obviously and letting go of empathy and
letting yes well that's also why we even
have two personality dimensions that are
separate we have agreeableness which is
basically the empathy dimension and we
have conscientiousness which is
basically the effortful striving
dimension or something like that
and they're both sources of moral virtue
right so okay so anyway
why is it so attractive why are so many
people identifying as well the first
part of it is
people don't necessarily regard
themselves as victims they tend the
activist types they tend to regard
themselves as spokespeople for the
victims
so when these rights well right so they
see an ethical
an altruistic ethical
motivation in that and regarded as
admirable and to some degree it is
subject to the constraints that we
already discussed but those are
important constraints
so
it's just not good enough that's the
thing it's it's and and it has this
marked disadvantage and then
you know there's all the ways that it
can be manipulated and shifted and
twisted and and
and and and used counterproductively and
that's highly probable unless you have a
saint doing it
so but the first level of attraction is
well
it is a pathway to to moral
behavior it is a valid pathway
and if you don't have a more valid
pathway offered to you
then
you know compassion for the dispossessed
is not a bad first pass approximation
but it's not good enough
and so you know that's maybe why you
should go to university it's like well
you've got to figure out what's better
than mere reflex of empathy
and you know there's the unearned
first of all what makes you think that
you're a spokesperson for the oppressed
what makes you think that you have that
right why should anyone take you
seriously how do you know you've got the
message right why do you think you have
the solution at hand how do you know
you're not more dangerous than the
problem itself how do you know that your
dark and unexamined motivations aren't
blinding you etc etc etc well that's the
issue but you know as i said you give
the devil his due and the empathic
striving is a valid source of moral
um endeavor
right yeah and when we can look
specifically on the racial dimension and
maybe this can elucidate some of the
underlying cultural pathology that's at
play here so in my experience as a young
person of color
somebody who's been
tormented bullied for his skin color in
elementary school all things which you
know you know i went through a hell of a
time in elementary school for for
looking different and being
mocked in so many different ways and i
used to wear a turban on the top of my
head as well you know being a sikh
background and so that was always a
point of
of uh being bullied and you know people
saying you know indian people are dirty
and you know you're brown and and you
know sort of yeah well you're gonna get
you're gonna get sorely tested if you're
different because
if you look at act like everyone else
you're not a
mystery but if you don't then you are a
mystery and how do children solve
mysteries well that's easy they poke at
them and see what happens so that's what
happened to you it's like you had a
turban it's like who's this well let's
make fun of them and see what happens
because if you want to find out who
someone is one way of doing it is by
making fun of them
yeah you know if they can take and i'm
this is i'm not saying this is
justifiable and i'm i'm not saying
anything at all about right but you know
generally speaking
the better you are at taking a joke
the less you'll get tormented all things
considered and so it is a reasonable
exploratory um mechanism although it can
go completely out of hand but it's
understandable yeah right so so i would
say there is a sign of progress here the
fact that that
after elementary school i wasn't really
bullied for my skin color and eventually
i did cut off my hair for various
religious reasons i didn't really
resonate with yeah and you know if you
hadn't been harassed for being a sikh
there's pretty high probability that
the kids who are prone to bullying would
have picked something else about you and
tortured you about that
it might not have been as horrible as
your ethnic identity say but
most kids are subject to a substantial
amount of provocative bullying right
yeah definitely yeah and just you know
putting aside the religious part of it
which is sort of another area of
exploration just the skin color part of
it let's look at that so you know in
ninth grade i remember this one
incident and the reason why i remember
this right now is because i i mentioned
this in my column from today in the new
york post
about um the council culture about
victimhood about racial transgressions
and all these things
and i remember in grade nine
uh being in this classroom where two
white boys basically singled me out and
they said you know you indian people are
dirty and just
all sorts of things of
using my racial identity as a point of
targeting me for my various
social
eccentric
behaviors my various you know problems
and flaws that i had using race as like
okay yeah the dirty element that's
really telling because one of the things
that regulates our intergroup behavior
is um disgust sensitivity not fear and
this is something everyone should know
we aren't really afraid of strangers
however we are easily disgusted by them
and that's worse because you destroy
disgusting things it's disgust not fear
it's a major political discovery that's
only been made in the last 30 years so
the dirty element that's really crucial
and also it's a terrible thing to be um
accused of right you're a contaminating
agent yeah exactly yeah that's a good
way to put it yeah right and that's a
shame with that yeah and i remember
being totally paralyzed in that
situation it was ninth grade all of the
other white peers and classmates they
were sort of paralyzed too they didn't
want to speak up for me
um and so i left the room crying
probably didn't know how yeah and it was
ninth grade too so it was embarrassing
to be crying in ninth grade oh
absolutely you're a teenager right
um
but so the point of saying that was that
yes racism exists we should acknowledge
that and
racism has impacted my life
at the margins i would say in various
individual incidents
and obviously you know you know i know
of people who are bullied far more
people who are white for being fat for
for just being socially awkward um
various other sort of things that can be
used as targets for bullying yeah about
75 of children have one observable
physiological abnormality that can be
used as the focal point for bullies
exactly yeah but so so the point that i
want to make here is that yes racism
exists and it has impacted me at the
margins but
but so this is sort of how i
how i came to
uh be sort of where i am right now so
last year i started writing about white
privilege intersectionality
the ideas of systemic racism and i you
know i noticed this
pathology of like
okay i'm a person of color yes i've
experienced racism but
i don't identify as a victim but it's
incentivized for me to be a victim for
me to be
protesting against white supremacy of
being this victim of systemic racism it
gives you an
easy as we discussed an easy pathway to
moral unearned moral superiority
which is really attractive because
earned moral superiority is unbelievably
difficult right i mean right there's
nothing more difficult than
this the the attempt to be a good person
that's hard and so if you can just be a
good person because you believe you know
the right three things well how
convenient is that and that's another
reason for
when people do take on the role of
victim
you know plus they can wield the club
righteously and that's i mean that's an
extraordinarily attractive option right
right and and one of the things that i
pointed out earlier in my writing last
year which was so
it was so influential and a lot of my
articles went viral right away was that
race is not a barrier to my success like
i live such a privileged life stop
telling me that i
suffer from you know racial disadvantage
or that other people have white
privilege that's helping them get ahead
like i found that to be totally
counterproductive and pathological like
that whole narrative why why was it why
did you regard it that way
because i want to take ownership of my
own life and there is no supernatural
force of racism that's keeping me down
right like i can write essays and
publish my work in all these influential
places and i get to talk to you here
right now and i'm at a fairly young age
and i'm doing all these important things
race has impacted me yes but it's not a
systemic barrier it's not stopping me
from succeeding in life but that seems
to be the narrative perpetuated by so
many white people especially that there
is this
overarching force of of of racial
victimization that's at play and so i
stepped in yeah well i think part of
that too on the part of the of the white
people let's say is that they get to
have and this is something that really
bothers me about the radical left um
you get your privilege and you get to be
moral morally superior because you're
standing up for the victims so it's like
you get to be privileged and a victim at
the same time it's like hey pick one
okay
like maybe it's just too much to be
privileged and a victim at the same time
and that really um i've that i
it's it's not a
an effective psychological practice it's
terribly socially divisive and it's
unbelievably hypocritical
you know anybody who comes to stands up
and says well you know i'm a professor
the system that produced me yeah was so
racist that it's or was so prejudiced
that it's racist it's like okay you just
admitted you have no moral claim to your
position resign
yeah now right
right right otherwise otherwise i
wouldn't say shut up because
no right people need to talk and they
need to express their opinions but
if you're if your statement is that the
system that produced you say as a
professor is so systemically prejudiced
that it it it's racist you don't have a
valid claim you're actually an
incompetent fraud
you've just said that yeah yeah who
who's being paid far beyond your
competence for reasons that have nothing
to do with your ability the only
truly ethical thing to do if that's true
is to stop doing what you're doing and
go find a job that you're actually
qualified to do
yeah yeah and i'm glad i'm glad you
brought this up here because
one of my earliest critics was the
editor of my local newspaper here um
for the chillax progress his name is
paul henderson and initially he was
critiquing my work and a very
progressive guy and you know that's fine
but he disagreed with me rejecting the
traditional narratives of
of white privilege and systemic racism
and that was great that he was
critiquing my work but then
then you know
he
was
targeting me for being associated with
alt-right that my articles rejecting
these racial grievance narratives are
are alt-right which is just a euphemism
for white supremacy right
and and one of the things that
so so so he wrote this column i remember
last summer
where it was titled something like dear
white people dear dear straight white
males in our city and so many people
read this and i remember
reading this vividly and
one of the arguments that he made was
that throughout history and even today
straight white males have
the dominant power in our society so and
he's a straight white male and so he's
saying it's time for us to listen to
people of color it's time for us to step
down and let them achieve some success
in our society and the irony was that
he's a straight white male saying that
and either you know like you said resign
for your unearned position or
you know even
you know listening to people of color i
remember this explicitly in the column
listen to people of color listen to
their struggles and this whole
stereotype of people of color being you
know victims it's like i'm a person of
color does my perspective matter and the
answer is no right it's it's the
individual
you know activists it's the the people
who align themselves with left-wing
ideologies that align with
uh well you know your your status as a
minority immigrant to canada yeah means
that you have some things to say to
someone like me let's say that that i
might benefit by hearing but to think of
that as
something that's going to constitute an
insuperable barrier between us
that's right
and and and to think about that as
fundamentally what you have to bring to
the table that's unbelievably demeaning
right i'm not talking to you because
you're young or because you're a racial
minority yeah i mean but i'm listening
to you
about your experience of those things
right but that certainly doesn't it
would be a horrible
it would be horrible if that's
what i how i conceived of you
i
mean the reason i'm talking to you well
it's because you asked that's part of it
but you know you're a bright young
character and you've
managed some accomplishments and that's
kind of interesting to me and
you have a
developing voice you're a competent
writer you're credible
despite your youth let's say
and so
and i wanted to hear what you had to say
and what questions you wanted to
formulate
that's why i'm talking to you
and it would be really something if the
only reason i'm talking to you
what were for reasons that
would make you easily replaceable of by
someone exactly your age and background
it's like who cares about you bring in
the next young sikh
because they're all the same anyways
right right there's this assumption with
these racial narratives that you jordan
peterson as a white man
you have a fundamental advantage in our
society because you are white compared
to me i have a disadvantage because i'm
because i'm of a certain skin color here
right that's that's the yeah well i
probably do have a bit of an edge there
all things considered well i'm not sure
about that well it might not be true it
might not be true now it might not be
true i'm you know i've certainly seen in
my in academia
if you're a white male a young white
male it's like forget it
and yeah forget it your your probability
that you're going to find a high-end
academic job which is very difficult and
unlikely to begin with it's vanishingly
small and it's not impossible but but
you have to be hyper hyper competent
so there are place there's definitely
places where
maleness and
right and being caucasian or working
against you it's definitely the case in
in academia it has been for 25 years
maybe longer
right yeah
yeah i just mean you know this idea of
white privilege is that because i'm part
of the majority culture
right i'm never the stranger as long as
i stay in my own culture
and that that that deprives me of
certain experiences but
it's easier obviously
so
we we can we can leave some residual
amount of explanation for success being
you know
arbitrary
racial prejudice that's fine
i think it's reasonable to argue about
how much of it's there and whether it's
flipped around entirely because it might
have by now
you know right yeah
but
and i certainly have seen in
organizations
law firms for example i worked with a
lot of law firms and if they have a
high-powered minority female oh yeah
they'll bend themselves into knots to
keep her and as they should because if
she's hyper-competent like great
hyper-competent people are rare but
but uh
and i've i've worked with women asian
women mostly who faced all sorts of
obstacles within law firms you know
angry men who were competing with them
getting in their way in all sorts of
ways so that still exists but that was
more at the level of one-to-one
competition the firm itself
generally did absolutely everything they
could to
right allow the career to develop
right yeah so it's not universally
advantageous to be a minority that's one
of my arguments so yes being a person of
color in a majority white classroom yes
i've experienced uh prejudice because of
that but in other spaces being a
minority is seen as a benefit right when
applying for various jobs you know
there's so much data on this too in the
united states of being
um of being black and being well you
definitely have an advantage if you're a
female and you're applying for an
academic position that's clear and it's
been that way for a long time with sat
scores there's affirmative action in
place if you're black and you're
qualified and you have
and you know you meet the sort of
minimum criteria you have a you have a
much higher chance of being admitted to
harvard yale
big law firms big tech google you have a
much higher likelihood of being
um accepted or getting the job compared
to a white person with equal standing
with equal credentials right if you're
black or if you're a minority you have
much more likelihood of uh of getting
unless you're asian and trying to get
into harvard yeah asians yeah that's
where
well that's why i see this so
interesting because i think a lot of
this intersectional nonsense is going to
be caucasians
especially male caucasians they're not
in the argument they they can't solve
the argument this is going to be settled
amongst the minorities that's how it
looks to me
right right yeah now so with victimhood
we've talked about the cultural part of
it and this is the crucial part is
asking about your experiences here so
so i'm going to segue into you now um
how did you
well so clearly you're not 100 recovered
right now as you've said i think you
said 40
before five
five percent
yeah right now i've had a good week a
much better week um i i was diagnosed
with sleep apnea not only like three
weeks ago i was waking up
i'm i was stopping breathing 25 times an
hour
wow and so i have no idea what but since
i have a machine now that that regulates
my breathing and
already now i i'm praying that this is
actually the problem but i've felt much
better since i've had this machine and
and right and the data suggests that you
continue to get better over about a
40-day period it's only been about a
week
so
you know maybe finally the finger has
been put on at least part of it and so
yeah and i like i've been in
excruciating pain yeah with unbelievably
high levels of anxiety unbearable and
then i also had a movement disorder
which i wouldn't wish on hitler himself
for 10 minutes it was absolutely
intolerable
um right and i've been so and i just
talked to my wife about all this this
week i'm bitter i'm angry i'm resentful
all of those things i shake my fist at
god it's like what's the justice in this
trying to scour my conscience to see
what i've done wrong it's and so that's
all victim
that's all victimhood
but it's not helpful i'm doing my best
to
drop that
you know life is unfair to many many
people and i think well this is a
special kind of unfairness and it
probably is but you know
that's
not rare
special unfairness is not rare
the tolstoy said you know every happy
family is happy the same way but every
unhappy family is unhappy in their own
unique way and i think unjust suffering
is like that it's it's arbitrary and
unfair
none of the victim
um
responses
have been productive for me i've tried
to fight them and off tried to fight
them off
so the temptation the attraction is
always there
you know because of what we face
you know how can you
your your parents died in an automobile
accident you're 13. like how can you
avoid feeling like a victim
you are a victim you are a victim
yes
yes so then what what le so but then you
think well i'm a victim and therefore my
anger resentment
is
hostility is justified and really it's
it's anger at god fundamentally
resentment at its core is anger or the
or at the conditions of being let's say
which for all intents and purposes is
equivalent psychologically to god
you shake your fist and say how can
things be this way and fair enough like
i understand that but it's not helpful
and it
does me damage i can see that even
though it's very difficult to escape
from it
you know when i can barely stand up
which is not an uncommon experience and
i can't even imagine how i'm going to
get through the next hour much less the
next day or the next weeks which i don't
even think about because it's like an
infinite landscape of pain
that anger and resentment they spring to
mind instantly but it's not
there's nothing in it that's helpful
yeah okay so you just basically answered
the question because we talked about
this before this podcast which was
how do you defeat the temptation for
victimhood of developing that mindset so
so you're continually struggling with
this
internal psychological turmoil of
like you said battling you know with god
and
dealing with this unfair just
extraordinarily unfair and
and painful situation that you're in to
put it mildly even
um
yeah i mean i've looked at my
contribution to it at least in so far as
i could i took benzodiazepines and that
seems to have been ill-advised i'm very
sensitive to benzodiazepine withdrawal i
mean when i took them i was really sick
i i was insomniac for
a long time weeks three weeks i was
freezing i couldn't get enough clothes
on i
my blood pressure was so low i couldn't
stand up i was like terror in absolute
terror i have no idea what happened
um and then i went to the doctor and was
prescribed this medication and i slept
and i felt better and i didn't think
much of it my life was very stressful at
that point and that turned out to be a
very bad decision
but i yeah and but
but but it turned out to be a bad
decision
i didn't do it
without cause i was genuinely ill and
so severely i didn't know if i'd be able
to return to work or or conduct any of
my
uphold any of my responsibilities so you
know i've looked at that did why did you
start oh yeah you were really sick
well why didn't why did you continue
well your life was stressful and and
you didn't
realize
i wasn't aware of how dangerous this
could be for some people
right so you you've been at this
this extremity of battling with the
victimhood mindset right because dealing
with what you're dealing with is
infinitely worse than dealing with
racism or
or well maybe i mean racism can get
pretty bad you know short sure i mean
sort of like my experiences like
dealing with racist people in society
like like so that's one aspect of it or
other forms of
suffering in your life of being broke of
being
you know all sorts of other things like
you've been at the extreme state based
on what you're talking about it was
extreme enough for me like
any more if it was any more extreme it
would have killed me
right exactly yeah yeah so you i
couldn't believe that i couldn't believe
many days uh many many days in the last
two years
i
truly believed that i would die before
the end of the day wow that that was i
just couldn't see how i could possibly
be
that impaired and live
it turns out you're a lot tougher than
you even want to be sometimes
yeah you're a lot more resilient you
know i mean people are we're very very
tough sometimes
so how does it mean morally or anything
like that i just mean
you're not that easy to kill
so how did this unimaginably difficult
period in your life how to change your
your perceptions of spirituality or your
well two reasons relationship with god
religion how did that change because
that's something
that's really important because some
people
like i described earlier when they're
suffering a lot in their life when
tragedy happens the attendee is religion
as a kind of crutch so people who don't
normally pray something bad happens then
they go to religion searching for
answers you know why am i suffering
other people when they're experiencing
tremendous hardship they
they lose their faith they're like
you know my right my mom died in a car
accident where the [__] is god yeah i'm
kidding why am i experiencing this so
and even if he does exist why should i
be his friend
exactly yeah so so you can go sort of
both ways either becoming more religious
in some ways or becoming nihilistic
cynical
misanthropic about society so i'm
curious where you what i learned was
that yeah um even though i had
i had already concluded intellectually
that there was nothing good about
nihilism and
and bitterness and resentment
that it was unbelievably
dangerous
and
that it isn't justified
under any circumstances
and then i entered these extreme
circumstances and i thought well this
justifies it it's like
i
i can't see how anybody could be in this
situation and not shake their fist at
god and and yeah and in outrage but i
really really thought it through and
talked to my wife about it and
and all i could conclude was that that
was wrong is that
it it didn't justify it
there was nothing good in it there was
nothing helpful in it all it was doing
was hurting me
it was interfering with whatever good i
still might be able to do in the world
um
you know the last chapter of my new book
is be grateful in spite of your
suffering and and that was a chapter i
you know
worked on and and was doubtful about and
returned to and was
like thoroughly
uh what irate about and
felt hypocritical about and and so on
and so forth the full gamut of emotional
responses but
it's the right thing
to do
to be grateful
it's it's and i'm not claiming this for
myself
it's it's tightly allied with the kind
of existential courage it's a decision
and you know
undoubtedly there are people who've been
pushed farther in the domain of pain
than me
burn victims people you know suffer
unimaginable agony
and i would never
dare to compare my pain to
someone else's extraordinarily
extraordinary pain it was certainly far
worse than
every day that i spent in the last two
years was worse than any day i had
before that by a huge margin yeah so
for me it was
well like i said if it had gone any more
extreme i can't imagine that i would
have lived through it
but they can okay so the first
conclusion was
you still under those conditions you
orient yourself upward and you try to do
good in the world and you and you don't
if you fall prey to resentment and
and anger and hostility however
justified
not even however rationalized but
however justified even if an objective
observer would say well no wonder you
feel that way
it's not helpful so there is no good in
it that's what you say i
then i wonder like like i i would agree
with you i'm inclined to agree with that
that there's no good in that but
but you know through you know there's
old cliched adage about going through
hard times revealing certain silver
linings and certain benefits that you
may not see in the moment so are you
open to that possibility of in the
future some
realizations there has been i guess that
that this thing we already discussed i
would say
is of benefit whether that benefit
justifies what i went through i would
say
so would i repeat what i went through
and still going through for that matter
i mean i've only been feeling somewhat
better for five six days
all right
i wouldn't repeat it to learn that
i think maybe you're still learning
something maybe there's still something
that's to come some realization i mean
i'm not
i'm not saying that's the case i know
you i know you're not well god only
knows right i mean right god it wasn't
until this last week that i really
thought that through and realized that
however
extreme my pain
which was diffuse
um yeah
um
it didn't justify
resentment it didn't justify ingratitude
it it didn't certainly didn't make those
things work but then the other thing
that i did realize was
and people have commented on that being
a difference between this book and the
first book the second book is more
communitarian there's less humor in it
because i just wasn't up to humor you
know
but
there's more emphasis on
uh cooperation and and and the social
role in ethical behavior and i think
that's partly a consequence of me
observing
how far above the call of duty
my friends and my family went while they
were caring for me and not only my
friends and my family but medical
personnel and
the general public who've been my well
the general public my viewers readers
and listeners let's say have been
unbelievably loyal and supportive and so
i've seen this outpouring of love
from
you know at the micro level within my
family and and from my friends
and
from
people i don't know but who i
communicate with um that's
well that saved my life for sure there's
no doubt about that multiple times many
many times and
has really
you know i saw my my father-in-law years
ago
sort of a man about town kind of guy
extroverted and and
gregarious and
and amusing and
a real character everyone in my small
town knew him he's still alive
his wife developed prefrontal dementia
and he took care of her over 15 years
and right and you mentioned this in the
book yeah he did a stellar
an admirable job i mean it just it just
floored me how
how he
how he did that with no complaints and
and
allowing help and
and loving her throughout her lengthy
lengthy decline that was staggering to
me to witness i'm i thought i'm not sure
i could do that it isn't obvious to me
that he's doing something that i'm
capable of doing and i certainly felt
that way about
my friends
many friends my my immediate family my
kids my wife my parents
but my sister in law
um
an old college friend who's still
walking with me virtually every day
um and then relative strangers that we
hired to help
to help with my care
also i yeah
um
my uh i'm in a state of jaw dropping
admiration for
the capacity of people to
love
yeah amazing so i i saw it more deeply
into that
and right so now i'm not saying that
made it all worthwhile it's like no
yeah no
not so far i certainly wouldn't have
drawn that conclusion but that's not the
point
right
you know here i am this guy you know i'm
a clinical psychologist i got tangled up
with benzodiazepines
um i'm talking to people about getting
their house in order and things collapse
around me and right like it's it's the
irony is well it's almost unbearable
that was part of what made this so
difficult
was not only the pain that physical pain
but
this absurd
paradox
and
yet people have forgiven me and right
yeah right yeah right now i'm amazed i'm
amazed you know we say that culture has
no capacity for forgiveness you know you
hear that about cancer culture and about
people who are being eradicated for
making one mistake and we have to learn
to forgive it's like i experienced a lot
of forgiveness and
and then again you know when i've been
attacked in the press when people have
gone after my reputation with all guns
blazing that's for sure
you know
our lives my family's life was
punctuated over the last five years with
two week periods where
i've been attacked for something accused
of something like you know
wanting the government to distribute
nubile women to undeserving men to
preserve social harmony
um right all these things that that look
absolutely reprehensible being compared
to hitler etc etc there's always a
two-week period after that blows up
where we have no idea
if i'm done
at that point
and yet
the support that i've received has been
continuous and so
why why that is
i don't know i think i i have hypotheses
i mean
i include myself in the audience of
reprobates to whom i'm lecturing
i don't assume that you know i abide by
all these rules they're they're targets
for
attainment
and
hopefully that
you know has protected me at least to
some degree against
the perception of undue moral
superiority
yeah now you sort of answered my first
question and then you answered one of
the other questions that i was going to
ask which was the the irony here of of
the guy who's supposed to who we're
supposed to go to for advice for
self-help wisdom somebody who's supposed
to teach us how to
put our house in order
has his house completely collapsed at
least psychologically speaking and so
actually too physically practically and
so this is what i wanted to pose to you
and you've sort of answered this you
know from a devil's advocate perspective
many people many people on the left were
saying this especially many prominent
journalists critics intellectuals like
like this guy is a complete fraud like
he went through like all this stuff he's
completely destroyed he can barely you
know get his his speech in order and
talk like so much suffering going on
um and so why should we read his book
about getting our own lives in order
like maybe this guy should take a year
or two get his life in order you know
fix whatever he's going through um and
then we can listen to his wisdom
afterwards but not right now while he's
dealing with this immense hardship and
again i'm not saying that but that's the
that's one of the the main criticisms of
your new book like without even reading
it is that you're
trying to teach the world you're trying
to impart your values
onto the world yet you have
gone through this
period where you've become completely
destroyed and petrified by these
these psychological physical uh problems
that you've you've dealt with
yeah right well believe me i've tortured
myself about that plenty yeah and i'm
glad constantly yeah i'm glad you see
that irony you said there is an irony
there yeah well you have to be pretty
blind not to see that yeah but you know
it's been a source of constant torment
and i was very apprehensive about
writing this book or certainly about
releasing it and
but
um
but what's your response i'm encouraging
people i mean what's your reason what's
your response to that critique though
that because you're going through this
much because you
don't have your
you don't have your house in order so to
speak in one way why should we listen to
you that's the question well i guess the
first thing would be is that
it isn't self-evident that whatever
happened to me was a consequence of not
having my house in order i mean if
someone has cancer you don't come up to
them and say well you know if you
if you would have just
you know acted more ethically that
you know you deserve what you get you've
got this cancer it's obviously your
fault it's like well my whatever
happened to me whatever my illness is or
was
wasn't as clear-cut in some sense as
cancer
so the edges are fuzzy but
but
you know everyone is susceptible to be
cutting off to be cut off at the knees
at any moment
that happens and you can protect
yourself against that to some degree by
putting your life in order and by living
properly and
and but that doesn't mean that you're
fully protected from it we all die
we all get sick
and so if we don't take if we can't
communicate with anyone
who doesn't get sick or die then we
can't communicate with anyone
and so does that mean we're all so
radically imperfect that we have nothing
to offer
and right no it means we're all so
radically imperfect that we should be
careful but
but
we're stuck with our inadequacies and
yeah
and i have my inadequacies and you know
yeah you can say well look look what he
did he should have known better it's
like that's possible it isn't
self-evident to me
what i did wrong i've had this right
propensity for depression forever it's
it appears familial it's affected
all my male relatives on my dad's side
pretty much very very intensely
um
and my children my my daughter not my
son he he seems completely free of it
um thank god oh so you've had this for a
while this is a natural well i've had
this propensity for depression for a
very long time right probably from the
time i was about eight years old maybe
earlier than that a long long time yeah
is that does that relate to like you
sort of being more serious in general
like lots of people have said like we've
never seen jordan peterson laugh a lot
like there was that one time where you
laughed really hard on theo theovon's
podcast and people were like oh that was
that was cool like well you know it's
funny because i'm
look since i've been launched into the
public eye let's say or launched myself
or whatever
since
i've become
notorious
my life has been very complex and and so
the
the levity has declined the playfulness
has declined and it's really unfortunate
i'm a very playful person all i did with
my kids was play with them and right
laugh with them and joke with them when
i get together with my son and my
daughter
and were healthy
which is quite rare because my
daughter's
very ill
very much of the time
all we do is laugh and and make fun and
play
you know when i tried to bring that to
my lectures i
uh before before making them public
let's say you know why
i
leave in my seriousness with
with jokes i i can't tell a joke to save
my life but i can say funny things
and i like talking to comedians and
um
so i if you had known me before you
would have thought that i was one of the
most most playful people you'd ever met
but you know since 2016
i mean things have been
complicated to say the least i mean my
my daughter was extremely ill my wife
was extremely ill and we thought for
sure she was going to die
she had a cancer that only 200 people
only 200
um cases have ever been reported and
every single one of those people died
wow
so and then she had terrible surgical
complications that were that appeared
that they were going to be fatal and and
so she lived on the edge of life and
death for five months and then and that
was just after i got back from
switzerland being in the hospital with
my daughter to have her ankle replaced
yeah wow and then at the same time
you know i was
i had this meteoric rise to to
public
notoriety fame yeah which hasn't slowed
down at all no um in fact seems in some
sense to be accelerating i mean we use
social media a lot and so we're
accelerating it i suppose to some degree
trying to communicate what
trying to communicate and to learn all
these technologies
but
you know and my reputation was on the
line
in in an international way
dozens of times and generally
what i've observed in people's lives is
if something like that happens to them
once on a local scale that's enough to
traumatize them
and that happened to me like every week
it's happened to me every week
essentially
in multiple countries
for like five years
so right yeah you know so people can
look at that and think well he should
have managed it better it's like well
okay fair enough you try it
yeah yeah exactly see how you do i don't
even want to say that i don't want to
say that because i wouldn't wish this on
anyone right i wouldn't wish it on
anyone yeah
i mean
i i i don't think i wouldn't wish it on
anyone for any reason and i'm not i'm
not complaining like i'm i mean
um
and you know you might also ask well why
did why do you think you have the right
to continue
because really that's the question why
do you think you have the right to
continue it's like well i don't
necessarily think that i certainly
doubted it
profoundly i thought well i'll get back
on my feet so what i did do first
some podcasts it's like well
do people find this useful
will they find it useful
how will they respond
well
positively okay
i'll do another one
yeah how will they respond
well
positively so i think well i'm i'm
either going to curl up and die right or
i'm going to continue
and so
i'm continuing and you still have your
you still have your wisdom intact like
as we're talking right now well that's
that's dude that's up to people to
decide and i say what i believe to be
true and if people find it useful well
good
but they're deciding that you still have
that intact right you're still a useful
figure despite well that's what they
tell me it's i watch the comments and
they say well you know yeah you you are
okay
and i listen to i talk to my parents
actually i talk to my parents every
night they're in their 80s
and they keep an eye on what i'm doing
and
they're encouraging thank god and
you know i'm i
i'm doing what i've done
before i'm doing what i've always done
i'm trying to figure things out
right and to communicate about that and
and lots of people are along for the
ride
and an ever-growing number i mean we
have
translations slated for 13 languages all
be launched this month
and we're using social media
to break down all the talks into one
minute two minute five minute segments
and we have a real
unbelievably qualified and and able
person doing that communicate with young
people on tick tock and all these social
media platforms
yeah and if people find it useful
it's up to them to decide
yeah
okay
um we have two loose ends here to tie we
have a couple of things that we should
that you've touched on which were
related to my questions so
so in the book yeah we have to stop we
have to stop real quick oh it's much
later than i thought so
oh wow holy
totally lost track well that's good
isn't it but it does mean it will have
to wrap up
okay um should i end off on i guess one
of the questions sure that i have okay
sure
yeah um so in the book you state that
you're frequently plagued with
doubts about the role that you play
um you know many people see you as this
kind of avatar that's science oriented
religion inspired that
is supposed to help us with our own
lives and you've touched so many people
obviously and you know i can talk about
so many people personally um you know
one person that in particular that i met
last year 17 year old girl at the time
she was going through an abusive
relationship and and she was listening
to your lectures during that time and
eventually she she escaped this
relationship through
watching your lectures and mustering
that self-determination that confidence
and that assertiveness to make that
decision of
of not being sort of psychologically
sort of held hostage to this person
right and and you know many people
um i tweeted this out last night many
people have this caricature of you
having you know a male dominated you
know audience for you know
men 25 and older or whatever but but
this was a young girl who was deeply
deeply touched by you and i just
remember it vividly and i i never forget
it so
so how do you make sense of this role
that you have like do you consider it a
moral responsibility to
empower people to give them the
psychological wisdom to
take action and
and find the self-determination like
with not to give it to them but not to
give it to them but to help them find it
right that's your role you consider that
to be yes that's my moral obligation
that's everyone's moral obligation
right but not everyone though like for
you it's different because you're an
author you're a public speaker right you
have the role now to to
tell yes it's too large your wisdom on
millions of people right very different
from anybody i hope to engage in a
collaborative process of finding wisdom
with millions of people
yes you know and well i i
i have my phd i taught at harvard i'm an
educated person i'm a product of the
best universities in the world
i'm the inheritor of the western
tradition
i'm a defender of that
[Music]
so you so you think you have that
responsibility to keep on i know
i know i have that responsibility
right clearly
i mean that's that's what you do with
your privilege
right
you turn your privilege into
responsibility
yeah
okay
what else would you do with it be
ashamed of it
hide it right right especially because
you're punish other people for it
yeah and you're helping so many people
too right so it's working right it's not
just some people are listening so many
people
young girls older men people in their
marriages people who are young people
like me who have listened to your stuff
and in large part you know me being in
this place you know being 20 and and
writing for some of the biggest
publications right now it's been through
listening to your lectures throughout
high school and
learning
learning so much right it's because of
you like even even just from an
intellectual perspective like listening
to your lectures on marxism
post-modernism quoting you in my
university essays and my lectures and
you know i mentioned that must have gone
down well
yeah yeah but you know in the colette
essay i i had your your video
oh there's an interesting eric my my
producer 1 million 64 000 females have
watched our videos on youtube within the
last 28 days way to be eric that's a
great stat
that's incredible
yeah
yeah but yeah but yeah just to finish
off like
like you've inspired me in so many ways
man like just just intellectually in so
many ways and it's a privilege i'm so
happy to hear it good work man keep it
up
who knows who you could be
you're only 20.
you get your act together man you're an
unstoppable force
yeah
and i i thank you for that so my
pleasure so please always always think
about always know the amount of people
that you're touching is truly
like near infinite so
you should you should
you should know that thank you
worked great man
thanks
you bet my pleasure
[Music]
you